hi my name is Vincent Staples and this
is me reviewing every [ __ ] thing from
the window to the wall to the sweat drop
down my ball you think Little John in
the influence can get to 365
collaboration like a little John [ __ ]
like a crunch it these are disguise they
already know this is gross it's a veggie
chip how is it sugar in this it's sugar
in this
I'm healthy but let's put him [ __ ] a
gram of sugar and a veggie stick just a
[ __ ] corn nut corn has bags are nicer
and they have a Cool Ranch corner black
people love Cool Ranch days cuz all
ranch is cool so why is the Cool Ranch
for this for us it's like kool
cigarettes Cool Ranch same thing black
people don't eat beets unlike all black
people eat beets like that were like
alive when the slavery was still around
no heat a beat but we've passed a beat a
long time ago it's not for us like
people don't need butternut squash
either we got to start respecting
people's cultures you know I mean next
time y'all got to get like the hot wing
Doritos over fire eight [ __ ] bag that
opens that for me is letting you know
that you don't want to eat it you don't
for a fact over disgusting [ __ ]
butternut squash that's a vegetable that
no one cares about no one's ever said
there's a shortage in the butternut
squash ball the butternut squash left we
would have less murders in the world ah
[Music]
down there's really horseradish on these
[ __ ] chips sprinkle Oh put them like
a steak hamburger some it's cool they're
disgusting but it's really horseradish
on next time you're doing pizza [ __ ] is
wrong with you guys